2026년 4월 29일 수요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 혼조세였습니다.
미국의 이란 항구 봉쇄 여파로 유가가 급등한 가운데
연준의 매파적 금리 동결까지 겹치며 증시는 하방 압력을 받았습니다.
연준은 기준금리를 동결했지만 향후 정책 전망을 둘러싼
내부 분열이 한층 깊어졌음을 드러냈습니다.
이에 투자들은 이르면 내년 금리 인상 가수에 대한 배팅을 늘렸고
미국 국채의 금리도 상승했습니다.
유가는 트럼프 대통령이 참모들에게 이란에 대한 장기 봉쇄를 준비하라고 지시했다는
월스트리트저널 보도에 상승했습니다.
이후 엑시오스가 트럼프 대통령이 호르무제협을 다시 열겠다는
이란의 제안을 거부했으며 이란 핵 프로그램에 대한 우려가 해소될 때까지
미 해군 봉쇄를 유지할 방침이라고 보도하면서 유가는 추가로 급등했습니다.
이번 연준회의에서는 내부 균열이 한층 선명하게
드러났습니다. 클리브랜드 연원의 해맥 총재, 미니아폴리스 연원의
카시카리 총재, 델러스 연원의 로건 총재는 금리를 동결하는 데는 찬성했으나
현 시점에서 성명에 완화적 기조를 담는 것에는 동의하지 않았다고 밝혔습니다.
반면 스티브 마이런 이사는 금리 인하를 주장하며 반대표를 던졌습니다.
파울 의장은 유가 상승이 단기적으로 전반적인 물가를 끌어올릴 것이라고 내다봤습니다.
또한 의장직에서는 물론하지만
연준 이사로는 계속 남겠다고 밝혔습니다.
시간의 거래에서는 메타가 지출 전망치를 상향 조정한 여파로 주가가 하락했습니다.
마이크로소프트는 장기적인 클라우드 부분의 성장세를 재확인시켰으며
구글은 탄탄한 매출을 바탕으로 주가가 상승했습니다.
에드워드 존스의 안젤로 크루카파스는
3명이 성명 문구에 반대했다는 것은
일부 위원들이 인플레이션이 이상보다 더 높고 오래 이어질 가능성에
있음을 보여준다.
이는 연준이 다소 매파적으로 기울었음을 시사한다.
lpl 파이낸셜의 제프리 로치는
3명의 어느 내 총재들이 금리 결정 자체가 아니라
그 결정을 시장에 어떻게 전달할 지를 두고 반기를 든 셈이다.
신임 연준 의장이 새로운 통화정책 기조를 안차시키는 과정에서
상당한 진통이 예상된다.
라고 전하였습니다.
2026년 4월 30일 목요일 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제지표는 22시 15분.
유럽.
기준금리 결정 22시 30분.
미국.
3월 pce 가격지수 22시 30분.
신규 실업수당 청구건수 22시 30분.
미국.
1분기 고용비용지수 22시 30분.
1분기 실질 gdp 성장률 22시 45분.
미국.
4월 시카고 연일 pmi 23시.
2월 경기선행지수 23시 30분.
미국.
2월 주ано.
그리고arias
.
출icias.ci
해설지.
liax.cj 8368.
gospel 다시 다시 들어와 얻었습니다.
indirPPС p 라고 적혀있는데 intentions with listed.
입력을 확인하며 access started to paper with p or i to confirm if it is in the
indirань에 입력을 받은γο 가능하신대로, 생활 처리가 선택iana